・・・
一同） ・・・
はじめしゃちょー）こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーと
たなっち）たなっちと
ライバロリ）ライバロリと申します、よろしくお願いします
はじ・た）おねがいしゃーっす
は）本当ポケモンの実況とかカードゲームを主にやっている、
は）バロリっていうのがいるんですけど
は）ここがぁ、お付き合いされていると…
バ）いやｗｗｗ　た）お付き合いはしてないですｗ
は）あ、してないの？(´・ω・｀)
バ）時々遊んでるぐらい…ｗ
た）東京でポケモンカードとかいろいろ教わってる
は）あーーー
た）戦闘フレンズゥ…
は）あ、戦ｔ、、、セフレ
バ）あ、戦闘フレンズ(焦)た)戦闘フレンズｗｗｗ
は)なんかすごい私に似ている友達がいるという
バ）あぁ、はい
バ）僕の友達の中に(半笑い)
バ）はじめしゃちょーにめちゃくちゃ似ている人が
バ）やっ、あのっ、それでいったらー、さっきあのー、
バ）近くのコンビニに行った時も二人で一緒に来たんですよ
は）はいはいはい
バ）普通にはじめしゃちょーと間違われてましたｗ
は）嘘でしょ！？そんなことある！？
バ）本当にｗそれはまじっすｗｗｗ
は）でもバロリと一緒にぃ、その人がぁ、
は）来ているという…
た）そうです
は）ことで、
は）では早速…
は）せーのっ
は）おぉおぉおぉおぉ
は）なるほどなるほどなるほど
た）似てますよやっぱ、マスクしてると
偽はじめ）マスクしてるとｗｗｗ※ちなみに声は全く似ていませんｂｙ字幕作成者
た）あと後ろ姿とかもめっちゃ…
は）後ろ姿…!
た）いやもう…うん
た）今のなんかはじめさん髪の毛今日色々あって
た）ワックスつけっちゃってるけど
た）だからつけてないはじめさんとほぼ一緒です
は）自分だとねイマイチちょっとわからないんすけどー
バ）すごいのが身長が一緒ってのが…
た）そうそうそうそう
バ）一番すごい…
は）あ、僕も185なんですよ
は）で、血液型が？
は）ぁぁぁ、ABなんですよ
た）すごいよそれ
バ）ｗｗｗ
は）ああっ！
た）ほぼほぼ　は）惜しいんです、ほぼ一緒
バ・た）ああ～
一同）ｗｗｗｗｗ
は）じわじわじわｗ
た）うん…おぉぉ…(小声)
た）おぉぉぉ…！！！
た）やっぱ後ろ姿わかんないっすわ
は）というわけでそういう、俺ー…がダイエットしすぎてしまったぐらいの偽物を今日呼んだんですけども
は）どんだけバレないのかっていう、企画をやってみたいと思います
は）一回じゃあ、けんすけで試してみる？
た）うん
は）一回ちょっと練習してみます
た）はい
は）今の角度やばい
は）あ～そこまで向くとちょっとあれだねぇ
偽）このへんすか？
は）うわっ…えっ？本当に似てる見てみ
けんすけ）(独り言)※小声
は）はっはっはっは↑ｗｗｗ
け）怖いんだけど…！？誰？
は）はっはっは↑ｗｗｗｗｗ
は）気付いた今？
け）んー見ちゃいけないもの見ちゃった…
は）はっはっは↑ｗｗｗ
け）え…？(困惑)
け）いや、はじめさんを見てぇ、こっち見て気付いた…
は）あっはっは(掠れ)
やふへい先生）え、けんすけー？
や）どこ？
や）あぁ、
や）お疲れっす
は）はっはっｗｗｗ
は）ｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
トマトクン）え？
だいちぃ）あれっ！？え！？えっ！？誰！？誰！？！？
だ）ねぇ誰！？誰！？！？誰 ！？！？！？
は）はっはっはっは↑ｗｗｗ
だ）誰！？誰！？
は）あっはっはっはっはっはｗｗｗｗｗ
だ）えええ…びっくりしたぁ！！ｗ
だ）え、誰！？え！！そっくりやんけ！！
偽）ｗｗｗｗｗ
だ）そっくりやんけ…！ｗ
だ）びっくりしたぁ…！！
は）というわけで、偽はじめしゃちょーでした～
偽）いえーい
だ）うーわっ！
た）いやまじで似てた～
は）すごいね！
た）すごーい
は）ちょっと横向いて
は）俺のコツを掴んだはずだなぁ
は）はい、ありがとうございます！ｗ